le ciel est d'un bleu intense le soleil
équatorial un brûlé blanchi la savane
nous sommes en afrique et plus et plus
précisément au kenya un pays qui m'est
cher pour y avoir commencé ma carrière
devant nous une famille de lion avec 3
ti lionceaux il est intéressant avant de
commencer de
d'informer que 90 pour cent de la
nourriture de cette petite tribu est
assurée par la lionne
suivant un instant cette lionne est
justement on a de la chance c'est
l'heure d'aller à la chasse
alors cette lionne elle va parcourir des
dizaines de kilomètres courir pendant
des heures pour
capturer une droits et sous ce soleil
harassant elle finit enfin par capturé
lundi l'ofs cette antilope une belle
antilopes elle fait un peu plus que son
poids que va-t-elle faire à votre vie
est là
elle pourrait faire le choix très
rationnel de
[Musique]
tracts est le plus rapidement possible
cette proie vers ce foyer avec les
petits lionceaux qui l'attendait qui ont
faim mais
elles manquent de force
c'est en plus sans compter sans sur les
prédateurs affamés opportuniste qui
profiterait bien de cet endroit servi
sur un plateau d'argent à bout de forces
notre l'yonne ne réussira pas à
atteindre son foyer
mais
la l'instant un animal est bien fait car
notre l'yonne va faire un tout autre
choix elle va décider de pratiques et
l'égoïsme sein ou dit autrement
l'égoïsme altruiste une fois cette tante
loeb capturer l à prendre le temps de de
se nourrir de se redynamiser de
reprendre toute sa puissance de l'yonne
et imaginer la suite à leur réussir à
tracter cette belle projet jusqu'à son
foyer en plus en protégeant sa proie de
ces prédateurs alors ce que la nature
fait merveilleusement bien pourquoi nous
une main avons nous tant de mal à
pratiquer cet égoïsme sans
je côtoie maintenant depuis quelques
années des chefs d'entreprise des
salariés et je me suis rendu compte que
bon nombre d'entre eux avaient des
difficultés à équilibrer leurs piliers
de vie voire certains étaient à deux
doigts du burn out
imaginons un instant un plateau avec ma
société où mon activité professionnelle
ma famille
mes amis et tous mon réseau social on
passe notre vie à appuyer sur ce plateau
à lui mettre la pression que se
passe-t-il alors
le le corps lâche et le plateau tombe
c'est le burn out
quand j'entends c'est l'entrepreneur et
ses salariés me dire que finalement ils
investissent ils ne consacrent pour eux
mêmes pour l'heure moi intérieur qu
entre 0 et 5 % de leur temps
la question est assez simple si vous
deviez investir ce faible pourcentage
pour la croissance et l'évolution de
votre société qu'en serait-il
et bien la réponse est simple
cette société aurait certainement vers
la feuille la cessation d'activité alors
comment puis-je un instant penser et
espérer que
caen ne me consacrant que entre 0 et 5 %
de mon temps pour moi pour nourrir ce
mois intérieur je ne vais pas moi aussi
vers la faillite la cessation d'activité
et le burn out
pour moi tout commence quand on comprend
qu'il n'y a pas un plateau mais deux
plateaux on a vu tout à l'heure déjà ce
plateau pourrait maintenant l'appeler
notre monde extérieur et donc vous
l'avez deviné l'autre plateau c'est
notre monde intérieur avec notre moi
intérieur et tout commence quand on
rééquilibre ces deux plateaux quand on
sait où on va mettre le curseur ou dit
autrement qu'est ce que je vais
priorisés dans ma vie pour avec des
actions concrètes pour que justement ce
0% deviennent 5% 10% 15% 20%
j'ai comme vous était mal outillés dès
ma naissance on m'a appris à faire mais
pas à ressentir ni à être réellement qui
me rappelle une anecdote
j'étais petit jeu j'étais en train de
faire un puzzle et j'étais dans cette
émotion impatiente
de reconstituer le personnage au milieu
avec toutes ces petites pièces avec plus
ou moins d'agilité et j'entends une voix
qui me dit oulala c'est pas du tout du
tout comme ça qu'on fait un puzzle non
non on commence toujours un puzzle par
les bords ça c'est la base laisse moins
de place je vais te montrer
ses bienveillantes tout ça n'est ce pas
la transmission du feu mais qu'en est il
de mon ressenti de cette émotion de
cette impatience que j'avais de cette
envie de faire ce puzzle selon mes
règles et à mon rythme dois-je
réellement faire ce puzzle comme tout le
monde où puis je le faire à ma façon
faire devient la normalité soit normal
et soit heureux
mais cette normalité
n'est rarement aligné avec ce que je
suis réellement à et avec ce que est ce
que j'aime
je suis absolument convaincu que
l'essentiel est de chercher mon bonheur
même si ce bonheur m'éloigne de la
normalité
même si cette recherche de bonheur
m'éloigne de mes mécanisme de mes
habitudes même de ma zone de confort
puisque cette normalité que je recherche
pour m'intégrer réussir performer
est ce que je suis vraiment moi-même
est ce que
si je suis sportif professionnel
est ce que je le suis parce que je peux
le faire
si je suis architecte cinq avocats
chercheurs chefs d'entreprise médecins
est ce que je le suis parce que mes
parents le souhaitez
on parle de bienveillance de
bienveillance au quotidien de
bienveillant son entreprise mais qu'en
est il de la bienveillance envers
moi-même
[Musique]
bon la soirée est déjà
bien avancé auriez vous un petit creux
parce que
j'ai envie de vous parler d'un
millefeuille par un grand mille feuilles
mais j'ai peut-être vous décevoir parce
que ce millefeuille les bas
il n'est pas très digeste même
totalement indigeste
ce millefeuille c'est quoi c'est la
superposition de tout ce stress et ses
contrariétés que j'ai au quotidien au
travail par exemple mais ça marche aussi
pour mon univers familial
ce rapport aura rendre pour hier ce cet
appel d'offres que je dois absolument
répondre en urgence ces journées de 10
heures absolument épuisante ces process
trop rigide et contradictoires ces
embouteillages sans fin ce manque de
reconnaissance professionnelle et me
voilà avec un grand millefeuille que
vais-je enfers en fin de journée eh bien
je vais l'emmener à la maison
que va-t-il se passer et bien une petite
erreur dans l'exercice de mathématiques
du petit dernier ou
cette musique trop forte de la grande et
encore ce pain à nouveau oublié
une étincelle une toute petite étincelle
et ce millefeuille va exploser en
éclaboussant toute cette famille qui
finalement il n'a rien fait pour
déclencher tout ça
ne pourrions nous pas
à mort des amants c'est tout ça en amont
en pratiquant justement
l'égoïsme 100
g comme beaucoup d'entre vous
certainement grandi dans une société et
dans une famille judéo-chrétienne et
vous avez sans doute entendu le fameux
aime ton prochain comme toi même moi
personnellement je mettrais avant cela
la fameuse injonction de socrate ce
qu'ils disaient connais toi toi même en
effet comment peut-on
aimer son prochain comme soi même si on
ne se connaît pas
est-ce que
je m'aime est-ce que je prends soin de
moi et ce que je prends le temps de me
nourrir de faire grandir cet être
antérieure de me nourrir avec des
passions des émotions du plaisir du
bonheur
de la sérénité de la spiritualité
est ce que
est ce que ma
ma famille ma société va s'écrouler
parce que je prends 1h 2h 3h 4h pour moi
par semaine juste pour moi est ce que on
ne prend pas soin des gens qu'on aime
alors pourquoi ai-je autant de mal à
prendre soin de moi et plus et au delà
de tout ça plus fondamentalement encore
est ce que je sais qui je suis
alors comment mettre tout ça en pratique
justement parlons de l'égoïsme 5
concrètement
ces cours de dessin que j'ai abandonné
il ya 15 ans cette moto que j'aimais
tellement et pourtant qui prend la
poussière au fond de mon garage depuis
dix ans et puis ces balades
seul que je faisais en forêt tous les
dimanches j'étais tellement bien
tellement ressourcer dans cette nature
est ce que justement je ne serai pas
plus aimantes
bienveillante
patiente
si je suis épanoui et qui libre m
c'est dernière décennie en cours
incluent deux choses la première est le
rôle absolument essentiel de la
confiance en soi et que l'on vaut bien
plus que toutes ces fausses identités
qu'on endosse pour
claire pour un être aimé pour être
apprécié et un peu intégré paraître
normal non
est-ce que je ne peux pas accepter des
fois de ne pas être reconnu par mon
entourage mais d'être vrai
deuxièmement je suis absolument
convaincu que personne n'a de prise sur
quelqu un qui est heureux il libre
alors faites vous confiance
libérez-vous
du poids du regard des autres est allé à
la rencontre de vous même de votre
propre chemin car celle là que la vie
prend tout son sens
je finirai par de phrase d'albert camus
la vie et la somme de votre choix alors
que faites vous aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]